[Música]
economía en directo américa y ya está
conmigo en el estudio daniel hablando
daniela bienvenida de nuevo la extrañe
cómo le fue en ese concierto de carlos y
en medellín incluso si concede mucho
raúl además que me dejen me recibió con
un clima espectacular le cuento regresó
a su casa este fin de semana bueno
daniela de vuelta aquí a bogotá y vamos
a hablar de los ricos que cada vez son
más ricos según un estudio de raúl y
volvemos y lo decimos no se necesita
tampoco un estudio para saberlo pero si
lo existe es el reporte de inequidad
mundial de 2022 elaborado por una red de
científicos alrededor del mundo y éste
dice que la proporción de la riqueza de
los hogares multimillonarios subió a una
cantidad récord en la pandemia el
informe señala que poseer efectivamente
algo colectivamente mejor el 35 por
ciento de la riqueza mundial frente a un
poco más del 2 por ciento a comienzos de
la crisis pero si estrechamos un poco
más el filtro raúl el 10 por ciento de
la población más rica tiene tres cuartas
partes de la riqueza mundial mientras
que la clase media posee poco menos del
25% y los más pobres no alcanzan a
atender a tener ni siquiera un 2% de esa
riqueza daniela cuántos multimillonarios
en el mundo y por favor restos a usted y
yo
exceptuando los a nosotros dos en la
lista anual de la revista forbes incluyó
este año un récord de dos mil
755 multimillonarios o sea dos mil 757
con nosotros ellos amasan una fortuna de
13 billones de dólares un 60 por ciento
más que un año antes y para hacer un mil
multimillonario anote se necesita tener
un patrimonio neto de más de mil
millones de dólares por lo menos fue
daniela ahora vamos a hablar de varios
productos de américa latina que están
catapultando las importaciones chinas
claro y es que china es el mayor
importador de materias primas del mundo
y se está reabasteciendo de productos
básicos como consecuencia pues de la
reactivación de la demanda en noviembre
las importaciones subieron un 31 7%
frente a octubre y muchos de los
productos que las impulsaron provienen
de este continente por ejemplo la soja
cuyas importaciones se dispararon en un
68 por ciento
llegaron más envíos desde eeuu otros
países como brasil y argentina también
son grandes proveedores de soja raúl las
importaciones de cobre entretanto
subieron casi un 25 por ciento en
noviembre hasta su nivel más alto desde
marzo perú y chile son líderes mundiales
en producción de este mineral rojo así
que deben estar muy felices otro de los
productos que están más importando desde
china son el carbón y el aluminio danny
y seguimos en china porque evergrande
sigue incumpliendo sus temas
claro mire y es que cuando una empresa
tiene una deuda en este caso evergrande
ellos dejan de pagar y tienen 30 días
para que no se les declaro un
incumplimiento formal y esto es lo que
está pasando porque de lo contrario se
está declarando este incumplimiento del
pago y en el caso de evergrande hace un
año hace un mes no pagó unos 80 y 2.5
millones de dólares en intereses de
deuda este grupo fundado en 1996 es el
segundo desarrollador inmobiliario chino
con más de 1300 proyectos en todo el
país tiene entre 150 y 200.000 empleados
y sus deudas suman más de trescientos
mil millones de dólares que es el 2% del
pib de china o casi 10 veces por ejemplo
el de bolivia y hablamos de ver one
evergrande every one than y entonces le
pregunto por qué hablamos tanto de
averiguar cuál es la importancia de esta
empresa en el mundo claro raúl más mire
inicialmente su crisis ya ha destrozado
por lo menos una docena de
desarrolladores más pequeños en china y
esto pues puede generar también un
efecto dominó sobre otros
desarrolladores en nuestros países
inclusive y en el mundo quienes han
observado más de cerca y con más
nerviosismo esta situación han sido los
inversionistas bursátiles el viernes ya
el grupo había sacudido a los mercados
después de reconocer que en cualquier
momento se quedará sin dinero y eso que
hace pues que muchos de sus prestamistas
se puedan ir a la quiebra como por
ejemplo instituciones financieras
contratistas hasta sus mismos empleados
bueno y hablando de belgrano le preguntó
entonces cómo están los indicadores
económicos tan mal yo la bolsa sobre
todo asiática por causa a la causa de
verdad pues mire lo iba haciendo hasta
que esta empresa de ver grandes anuncios
que este martes que creará un grupo de
control de riesgo incluyendo también
funcionarios del gobierno y eso ayudó a
que las acciones hayan repuntado a su
vez también la desde la bolsa de hong
kong y las otras bolsas asiáticas los
mercados de europa también repuntan a su
nivel más alto en una semana están
imputados impulsados en esta ocasión por
una fuerte alza en las acciones
tecnológicas que ha mitigado las
preocupaciones sobre la variante de
omicron de el coronavirus y que tenía la
bolsa pues muy mal cifra el día raúl la
cifra del día son los 41 mil 580
millones de dólares
exportaciones récord de taiwán en
noviembre subieron por decimoséptimo mes
consecutivo esta vez un 30 por ciento y
están impulsadas por la creciente
demanda de productos electrónicos para
navidad usted sabe que taiwán es uno de
los principales exportadores y también
es uno de los principales productores de
chips aunque la exportación de
semiconductores se disparó en un 27 por
ciento todavía no son suficientes usted
va a comprar un carro y no lo encuentran
bueno pues yo no he comprado todavía
muchas
gracias por toda la información
económica nos vemos más adelante con más
economía regresamos a la china porque el
reportaje del día se trata de edward hoy
somos chinos